[Music]
come on come on little s get in the car
hey it'll be fun like cartoons it'll be
be fun okay it's like a game Hide and
Seek I'll drive fast right let's go let
be right come
on this is hella fun this is why don't
you want to get in the car it's a lot of
fun get in the damn
car
[Music]
my
see
bels they've come for me I have to help
there's nothing we can do I have to help
Alfie we got to
go Alfie
Alfie oh help no
fight
up
oh
[Music]
Shipley it's how answer the phone
Shipley I know you're there colel Taylor
where's Shipley I'm with it right now
he's he's in pretty bad shape all right
listen to me did you locate the weapon
yeah it's here I'm with it describe it
it's a kid it's it's a kid they make it
into some kind of
kid that's the weapon what I can't reach
you you have to bring it to me do you
understand no Shipley can't move I mean
he's he's not looking good at all police
the everywhere I don't know how I'm
getting out right now I don't even have
an exra strateg right now then you know
what you have to
do kill it what look
colel
how she can stop it she's not ready yet
the range of her powers are still
roing but if we can get her up there
maybe she can destroy
it how could anyone survive
that she
won't but it will turn the tide of the
war does she even know what she's been
created
[Music]
for when the war
started they protect to
me took better care of me than humans
would
have they not people
Maya it's just
programming 10 years ago today the
artificial intelligence created to
protect us detonated a nuclear warhead
in Los
Angeles this is a fight for our very
existence Sergeant Taylor we are this
close to winning the war
the AI are developing a super
weapon retrieve
it or they
[Music]
win did you locate the weapon yeah it's
just a
kit are you going to heaven no you got
to be a good person to go to heaven so
we're the same we can't go to heaven cuz
you're not
good and I'm not a
person do you have any idea with that
thing is she looks like a little girl
now but she's
growing Whoever has that kid wins the
war who side you want
huh what do you want sweeetie for Rob to
be
free oh we don't have that in the fridge
how about ice
cream
did you locate the weapon yeah describe
it it's a
kid John David's character is supposed
to destroy this weapon but it happens to
be in the form of a six-year-old child
hey hey pay attention my name is not bot
my name is Alfie remember usually robots
in movies are all cold but with Alfie we
keep the humanity in it forces John
David's character to start questioning
everything he thought about AI are you
going to have no you got to be a good
person to go to heaven it's hard to make
a decision empathy or self-preservation
what do you want sweetie for robots to
be free we don't have that in the fridge
how about I ice cream it was so good for
the movie that mine JD bonded Maddie
forces me to be honest where's my wife
tell let's go go ahead where is my wife
they were inseparable
the she's extremely talented and
fearless they're coming to get me trust
me I'm getting you out of
this Maddie is a special human being to
be able to emote the way she does to be
able to bring such life into this
character it was amazing action I have
to help there's nothing we can do I have
to help Alf we got to go they convey so
much it just looks just feels really
unique you know what you have to do I
can't do that like you
want have to help
[Music]
her my favorite Cinema is very visually
driven it's not like a play It's like a
dream it's just a pure
emotion this film's a mounting pot of
movies I grew up
loving Vietnam movie mixed with robotic
sci-fi they've come for the
child Gareth has this ability to inject
compassion in a Sci-Fi genre that
usually leans on spectacle and danger
fire Gareth Edwards he is a Visionary
and these characters are all relatable
and you fall in love with them I thought
oh my God sign me up I want to be a part
of
this what jumped out was magical realism
that he was able to
execute the depth in emotion that he was
able to capture in every frame they're
my family they're not people Maya
they're not real you and I are real this
isn't real okay and cut good the film
deals with a lot of big themes like what
does it mean to be human and what does
it mean to be alive and can love
transcends those divides and boundaries
you're my friend should we embrace it
should we destroy it everyone ready and
action Gareth shoots in a way that a lot
of actors love because he doesn't like
to cut keep going keep
going I love that process where we do
these rounds it just
takes he operates the camera himself you
he knows what he wants yeah he's not
afid to anything and anything
goes we really went for broke it's just
a really insane Rich visual Journey that
I hope affects people in the way that I
was affected when Cinema blew my mind as
a
kid hey give him back what you what are
you
[Music]
do